cool
thank you for coming today I'm attorney
Gloria Allred and I'll be reading a
statement and then uh Nicole will be
reading her statement
after the statements we will be playing
the video of the incidents
we are here today to announce that we
filed a lawsuit yesterday on behalf of
Nicole lechmonic against yea formerly
known as Kanye West as a result of his
assault on her on January 27th 2023 in
Newbury Park California
the lawsuit that we filed in Ventura
County California contains the following
allegations against the defendant yay
at approximately two o'clock to three
o'clock P.M on January 27th
2023 Nicole also known as the plaintiff
was in the vicinity of The Sports
Academy in Newbury Park California
she had filmed Kim Kardashian going into
the sports academy and plaintiff was
driving her car while taking a break
during the interval of time before Miss
Kardashian emerged after the sporting
event that she was attending
the plaintiff unlocked the plaintiff was
lawfully engaged in her vocation
and was among other professional
photographers outside the sports academy
filming Miss Kardashian as she was
driving
plaintiff noticed an interaction between
defendant yay and another photographer
on A Street near the sports academy
both had exited their vehicles and yay
was angrily confronting the photographer
Gibbon defendant yay's reputation for
violence against photographers his
history of physically harming them
and based on his threatening body
language plaintiff became fearful for
the photographer's safety defendant yay
went through his pockets and plaintiff
thought that he might have a weapon
from her car plaintiff began filming the
incident on her cell phone
with her hand extended outside the
driver's side window
plaintiff remained in the driver's seat
as she was filming she did not want to
get out of her car because she was
afraid of the defendant yay
defendant yay was enraged he reached
into plaintiff's car and ripped her
phone out of her hands as he did so
plaintiff was fearful the defendant yay
had a weapon or would strike her
defendant yay then threw her phone onto
the streets
towards oncoming traffic
next defendant yay walked to the other
side of her car where plaintiff's
business partner was also filming from
the passenger seat
plaintiff's business partner was
likewise terrified
he locked the door and he rolled his
window up
as defendant yay arrived at the
passenger side of the car plaintiff
remained fearful as to what was going to
happen next
defendant yay gave them a quote death
stare end quote
before finally turning and walking away
as a result of what yea did to Nicole we
are suing him for assault battery
negligence and violation of her civil
rights our complaint alleges that the
California Constitution Article 1
Section one
of the Constitution guarantees certain
inalienable rights to persons in this
state and has been construed
to specifically include the fundamental
right to pursue a lawful
occupation
at the time of this incident Nicole was
a professional photographer in
California and we allege that at the
time of this incident yea attempted to
interfere with and did interfere with
her fundamental constitutional right to
pursue her lawful occupation
as a result we are seeking General
special and punitive damages according
to proof at trial
we are seeking a court order
preventing yea from attacking or
otherwise interfering with plaintiff or
other photographers right to pursue
their occupations
yea has a prior history
of assaulting photographers
and we want them to be accountable
we are bringing this case because Nicole
wants yay to know that what he is doing
to photographers is wrong and in
Nicole's case
it was harmful to her physically
emotionally
and financially Nicole wants Justice and
that is why she filed her lawsuit
against yea
yesterday in addition she wants him to
stop interfering with the rights of
other photographers to engage in their
lawful occupation
Nicole and I look forward to seeing yay
in court
and now I like to introduce Nicole Lech
Monica
would you move over a little pieces for
sure
I am a photojournalist my focus is
celebrity news it is my profession from
which I earn a living
the incident with the a formerly known
as Kanye West was traumatic to me
he reached into my car as though he was
going to hit me he grabbed my phone out
of my hand and then angrily threw it
into the street
he caused me so much fear I have not
been able to be same since then his
actions have interfered with my ability
to work
although I am not a world famous artist
as yay I have just as much of right to
work as he does
he has no right to assault me batter me
or cause me to be afraid to pursue my
profession
I want yay to know that he cannot do
what he did to me without facing
consequences
I am determined to stand up for myself
and let him know that he must change his
abhorrent Behavior
thank you
and uh
we will now show
two videos
uh the first will show what happened
prior to
the defendant approaching Nicole's car
and the second will be what happened
when he approached her car
so are you
okay we're going to restart it for the
audio and this is also the second one
not the first so let's try
we'll start again
Kathy audio too
now they're gonna run above me like that
if I say I wasn't running
like that if I say stop
with your cameras
okay do we have another one
that was both yeah okay all right
this is also a copy of the lawsuit that
we did file yesterday
for Nicole
and while we don't have a case number
yet
we do have evidence of it's being filed
and that is right here
from our attorney service and there's a
stamp from the court that says received
Ventura Superior Court May 31st 2023.
all right so
we'll be happy to take a few questions
I'm going to provide a copy copies of
our statements and
afterwards was there a crime report
filed with the Ventura County Sheriff
she did file a police report
what was the resolution of it pardon me
what was the resolution of it uh as far
as we know no charge has been filed
six months of the mature Academy I have
not had contact with them I don't know
but at this point no charge has been
filed yes
the deputy's response yes
and then what happened
basically they came to me and wanted to
get my
um
information of what happened after
the incident and you gave them the
information yes
was that the same day yes it was
any response from the District
Attorney's office
well not from I've had no contact with
them at all attorney's office or with
law enforcement
have you been have you received any
response from the District Attorney's
Office no
did you receive a call from a detective
possibly
following up on the case though
I have I did speak to them and they were
you know they just basically wanted to
tell me that it was filed and
and to go from there so
Nicole what would you say to people on
social media who are actually defending
Kanye's actions what do you want them to
know about your profession profession
and your ethics as a journalist
well I've been doing this for over sorry
for 10 years and
um
I just think that the people do not
understand the uh
hardship that we go through you know as
far as photographers
um we are legit journalists I've never
had any other incident
happen like this with any other
celebrity I have a you know clean
uh communication with you know the
celebrities
um you know I go to New York Fashion
Week and and things of that I enjoy
doing fashion photography I mean it's
and news for that matter and nothing has
ever escalated to this
what I want people to know is that there
are good
people that do this
profession
we are not
you know we're we're good people so
as far as that and what was the other
part of the question
to them to know about yourself and how
you conduct yourself as a journalist yes
I've always you know minded myself as
far as the laws and
um
we are mindful we care about the
celebrities you know we're always
concerned about their well-being I would
never do any harm to anyone
um you know I'm always you know
most people know me in this industry and
have I've been in it for over 10 years
so I just wish that people would
understand that this is a legitimate
profession
and we are
we are getting news we are taking
photographs and such and I wish that
people would be
you know especially Kanye more
compassionate
and kinder
yeah I will say that
yeah of course this is my not my first
uh
lawsuit against miss you know
uh formerly known as I don't know if he
was formerly known as Mr Kardashian West
but formerly known as Kanye
um
so uh
because in 2016 you probably read this
on the Internet it's there that I
represented another photographer
who was attacked by Mr
formerly known as Kanye West Mr yay
and uh and we litigate that that case
was settled
uh after a while with an apology
to our client and we're not discussing
other aspects of the settlement but uh
was let's put it this way
not just an apology
but
now
it's happening again
and
this is just not acceptable
it's understandable to essentially also
answer your question sir
that the public knows celebrities so
they tend to like them they tend to side
with them they think they tend to think
some of them do that whatever they do is
just fine and should be supported
point is that photographers
professional photographers who earn
their living
by being photographers
photojournalists
have a right to do that without being
interfered with by a celebrity
he can
Express his displeasure
using words
but he does not have a right to grab
someone else's property
in fact that property being
the tool that is used by a photographer
to make his or her their living
and stop them from being able to earn
their living by filming what is going on
at that moment
he needs to understand he was in a
public place
the street is a public place
anyone whether they're professional
photographer or not has a right to film
in a public place
if he doesn't want to take the risk of
being filmed
he could choose to stay in his home
where he'll have privacy but he's in a
public Street
so he's going to have to stop whether
he's prosecuted or not that's a decision
by the District Attorney's Office in
Ventura County
he's going to have to pay the
consequences
this can't continue
and I do want to commend Nicole because
she's not only doing it for herself and
it's painful for her to have to
recollect what happened and see what
happened over and over
if she doesn't want this to happen to
other photographers
yet some people think of photographers
as a despised class
except that if it weren't for the
photographers they may not know what
they want to know about their
celebrities
for whom they're fans
so
stop criticizing the messenger so to
speak
because that's who they are
but you can criticize all day if you
want you have the right of free speech
and so does yay
he doesn't have the right to grab
someone's camera I might add
that
hers is not the only complaint that I
have received recently by a professional
photographer
but the complaints I've received
recently were against
some other celebrities
so other celebrities really need to pay
attention to this
is not going to be tolerated
okay not going to be tolerated
we are interfering with someone's
livelihood
so I'm going to look forward to
yay's response Gloria I have a question
for your client sure was she working
freelance for herself or is she working
on the apple of an agency we know
there's a lot of agencies yeah do you if
it's up to you if you want to answer
I do work as a freelance photographer
and I work from
multiple possibly agencies you know but
I am a freelance photographer so that's
how you earn your little yes so that
video that we that we saw both of them
were those sold to an agency or anybody
we're not going to answer that but she
does
you know filmed for a living let's put
it that way right but thank you for your
question the video that's shown were you
in the car the whole time along with
your compatriot you didn't get out you
didn't get close to Kanye party to yay
or anything that was going on there you
were basically shooting from a distance
yes
there was no personal interaction before
that he looked back just saw you guys in
the car he approached you you didn't
approach him in any way shape or form no
did he object say stop filming stop
doing this and that or was it just
he was he was ticked off the fact that
he was confronted by one photographer
and then just decided to come after you
yeah you saw what happened yeah that's a
fair question there's no there's no
indication at this point that you make
any kind of advanced toward you at all
no I am not an aggressive person in that
manner so let's and to drill down on
what Pete said
in other words at no point were you out
of the car prior to his approaching your
car and the window while he was there no
I was not outside the car
at any point that day did you follow Mr
yay's movements in his vehicle with the
other photographers basically falling in
wherever he was going
no not prior to that
for those who couldn't hear that
question the question was at any point
prior to the incident where you
following uh what Mr well yay's
movements
uh uh no right no okay thank you but you
were you had your
phone in your hand right right
out the window of your car while you're
in the driver's seat yes and you were
filming
his interaction with another
photographer that was ahead of you is
that correct yes
that's what happened
okay any other questions okay yes oh we
have a question from the zoom
has the incident affected your ability
to work since it occurred and if so in
what ways
yes it has some as far as emotionally
um I'm really not as motivated to work
um you know it's had a it's had an
effect on Me overall
um so that's basically
how I feel yeah in other words are you
concerned that you might be
assaulted again is is that why you're
not so motivated to work is that a
possibility from it by a celebrity
yes it is a possibility but
I'm just fearful you know in my in my
mind as far as that okay
any other questions
from the zoom
all right thank you very much for coming
and we'll provide everything to you
thank you thank you thank you
recordings
okay
did you give it to them
thank you so much
for a year
be in the parade